sur la plaque du village ce matin au
journal du dimanche c'est la fierté qui
domine en voyant ce classement
mais oui on débat on est fiers russe a
fait d'eux un peu plus de deux ans qu'on
est là la fierté mais pas la surprise
car tous les habitants que nous avons
rencontrés se disent très chanceux de
vivre ici pourquoi il fait bon vivre ici
l'environnement l'ambiance la nature à
côté c'est un peu une grande famille
donc c'est agréable quoi l'exécutif sont
bien à la campagne pas loin les bois
palois les commerces à côté à quelques
mètres du chantier de la future école
primaire et maternelle dans cette maison
brice miolane vite ici avec sa famille
entre ville et campagne facile d'élever
ses enfants ici ah oui oui c'est surtout
les enfants qui sont faciles
c'est la proximité en fête qui commence
à parler de quoi et puis après on peut
aller se balader les champs tout ça
c'est sûr les activités sportives avec
les enfants à l'extérieur c'est ça c'est
facilement ya le plagiste en bas il ya
des petits magasins et les bowling et à
tout ce qu'on veut ici c'est agréable
c'est pas comme ça on était en ville là
on n'entend pas les voitures au maire
heureux de ce classement qui n'hésite
pas à montrer le cabinet d'ostéopathe de
kiné ou encore ses commerces alors le
café au bon vin bas c'est un vieux cafés
de la commune on a la chance d'avoir
encore deux cafés dans notre commune ce
qu'est ce qui est assez rare dans des
communes de 1500 habitants on est proche
de la métropole on a les services de
soins on à la clinique de valmy est
juste à côté on a aussi les services
culturels le zénith de dijon il est pas
loin de lui à 5 minutes les clients
bénéficient du fait qu'on me garder
rival et on essaye de le garder la
commune a gagné plus de 200 habitants
entre 2013 et 2019